move to get to the shot he lost that one
be and still got to It Candace is
turning away because this is a very
scary sight we have a lot of unanswered
questions about this Joel embiid had
gone up and back to the locker room
multiple times throughout this game he
had a play earlier with him and Draymond
where he collided but this he he comes
up injured on the ground in
pain again watch kaminga here as he
falls onto the
knee
and he has taken off we are going to
wait for more word on this he had missed
the last two games and again he's
getting close to that Mark where it
won't be a full 65 where he won't be
eligible for MVP where he won't be
eligible for all MBA something to keep
your eye on and again he had a a streak
I believe of 22 straight 30 plus point
games that comes an to an end tonight uh
you're sh but you can tell he wasn't
right correct um um all of us up here
have played through injuries and have
played through things but you could tell
from the moment the jump ball happened
that he was not right and you know when
you play like that especially at his
size and his position and how much
impact he has on the offensive and
defensive end it's just unfortunate
because you have the season you know
76ers season is in his hands and to see
something like this happen time and time
again
man goodness oh my God he's talked about
his goal is not to just win MVP is
Championship winning Championship so
leading into Allstar break and after you
want Joel embiid as healthy as possible
to play his best basketball MVP
basketball so you know I I hope it's
minor looks you know look bad but I hope
he he's minor he'll be ready to go can
we uh put up the graphic of the games
missed and and the guys that are getting
close to the point where they're not
going to be eligible for those
postseason Awards and this is not just
about Awards there's contract money tied
into some of these postseason Awards as
you see there embiid halberton and
embiid are dealing with this right now
halberton did say he came out and said
it's not a rule that he likes uh his
coach even came out to his defense do
you think Jamal this is factoring into
someone like embiid's mindset about
playing hurt and not resting up for the
playoffs I hope not because we all want
these guys to play like that's what they
do that's what we do as athletes but if
we're risking further injury or
compensation or anything for that I I
understand what the NBA was doing as far
as okay let's get these guys playing but
not if if Jo and beid is hurt it doesn't
matter if they're Sixers second third
fourth and fifth option are unbelievable
it won't matter and for the league
that's not good because these guys are
so important so I'm just hoping it's not
serious and we'll have to look at that
because as fans I don't have a vote I
think you have a vote left Co MH even if
they play whatever number it is people
still have to vote for them if they made
it or not they don't have they shouldn't
have to risk themselves in their their
livelihood to say I need to meet a quota
to be eligible for this stuff I think I
never like to talk about a person's
pocket and what they're making but it's
real money that they're losing by not
making all NBA the Tyrese halberton one
is the most glaring he just signed the
major extension if he makes any of the
all-nba and because he was a All-Star
starter you would think he's on the
track for that it's a $54 million
difference if he makes it or if he
doesn't and so halberton played today
and they are trying to get players to
play so you understand I don't think the
intent was harmful I think I think Rick
Carlile who's the head of the coaches
association said we will need to talk
about this after the season but I don't
there shouldn't be something like this
that's say here's there's the problem
like he he he played but is he playing
because of that for that money to you
know he risking injury because of that
that's what I'm saying or is is he
risking injury or it's like oh okay I'm
good now you know so I I mean I think
the n NBA is in a tough position because
they're trying to you know Remy the the
issue which is fine and it's just it
just might need to be tweaked just a
little bit you're going to need tweaks
you're going to go through you know es
and flows and you know but you're
getting situations like a Hal Burton a
situation like a Joel embiid who clearly
is playing at an MVP level and you know
but clearly in injured and if he goes
down this could be a situation where he
miss misses those games that he needs
the coach of the Philadelphia 6 76ers
are now 29 and 17 four game losing
streak Nick nurse took the podium let's
take a listen to what he had to
say have anything you can share with us
on Joel on his yeah so um he uh
obviously got landed on uh so they're
going to do an MRI tonight or tomorrow
um
it's kind of unrelated to what's been
bothering him um so we just wait on that
yeah so you guys saw the play was land
there and got landed landed on Y what
were the conversations in in clearing
him two play tonight General and how did
he feel before before that play happened
how was he feeling how was he yeah so
obviously medical cleared him uh Joelle
obviously is a big part of that he said
he was feeling good um
I you know he said he's more a little
rusty and and he been you had been on
the court for for five days um but he
said he felt
good all right it'll be something that
we do monitor he was dealing with a left
knee injury this is again the leading
score in the NBA three 36 points per
game
I